rather than having israel's back senior
democrats
have actually pressured israel to end
its defensive
operations they've called for a
ceasefire and urged leaders to
strive for peace through a negotiated
two-state solution
netanyahu is out there saying that he
has a blank check from the united states
that's what he's saying he says he's
this is going to go on
for more time and that the united states
is with him
no we're not there are many members of
congress including supporters of the u.s
israel relationship like myself and
others who are saying that netanyahu
does not have a blank check
well the white house dealing with very
vocal members of their
democratic caucus up on the hill about
the issue of
israel its actions against hamas the
white house putting out a readout of the
call with israeli prime minister
benjamin netanyahu
president biden spoke with israeli prime
minister netanyahu today the two leaders
had a detailed discussion
on the state of events in gaza israel's
progress in degrading the capabilities
of hamas
and other terrorist elements and ongoing
diplomatic efforts by regional
governments and the united states the
president conveyed to the prime minister
that he expected a significant
de-escalation today on the path
to a ceasefire no indication yet that
that has happened
we'll see if it does let's bring in our
panel bill bennett former education
secretary host of the bill bennett show
podcast
susan page washington bureau chief at
usa today and the author of the book
madam speaker nancy pelosi and the
lessons of power
and ben dominic publisher of the
federalist
susan speaking about speaker pelosi she
is
having to kind of let her uh caucus
speak its mind on this foreign policy
issue but
the byte administration seems to be
trying to tiptoe
through all of that yeah i think
president biden had hoped to be
as little engaged in this as possible
uh he certainly hasn't been as outspoken
as some even in his own party and
i hope he would be got a little farther
forward today in his conversation with
netanyahu but of course democrats are
divided
on the issue of the conflict between
israelis and palestinians and there are
significant number
on the progressive side who thinks the
united states should do much more to
protect palestinians
even at the cost of pressuring our
longtime ally
israel it is a difficult situation for
the president
uh and it's one that i think uh pelosi
is well aware of because she has all
these different voices
in her own caucus ben uh republicans
obviously are jumping on this saying
that there is a hamas
caucus within the democratic party
it is not a difficult situation with the
president the president
ought to stand with israel as america's
long time alley ally in the middle east
but unfortunately
i think we see a situation here that the
iranians are looking to exploit
they have been on their heels thanks the
last four years the trump administration
which saw them
really hurt in a lot of different ways
uh both you know
seeing the the top of their uh military
uh
uh exercise you know essentially
knocked off thanks to both the israelis
and
the americans but also i think they see
a situation where
they're trying to seize this moment to
to lean
into this new administration which has a
lot of distrust
with israel and with bibi netanyahu
and in in trying to essentially attain a
new uh dynamic that would allow them to
restore what they were trying to do
back in 2015 unfortunately i think we're
seeing a situation
where the incompetence of the biden
administration their inconsistency when
it comes
to foreign policy is leading to benefits
for our enemies overseas bill there are
some experts foreign policy experts not
just republicans who say that this all
points to iran
and its ability to funnel funds
to hamas and and to produce this this
moment
well certainly uh the funds that uh went
to iran
uh were used to make these rockets which
were being launched into israel
and i think bibi netanyahu will stand
his ground as i know him
he will but further we are now talking
about giving iran more money remember
going back to the table
which means potentially fueling more of
this giving them more funds to produce
more more rockets i'll split the
difference between
susan and ben i agree with ben it's not
difficult in terms of right and wrong
here who started this fight
and why did they start it because they
think there should be an end to the
state of israel
but it's a difficult situation for biden
because he doesn't know what he thinks
and he's being pressured by the by the
left caucus
and of course he also wants to keep good
relations with our greatest ally in the
world
bibi netanyahu knows who he is knows who
he is
knows what he wants to do biden is in
the process of figuring it out
welcome to the job mr president meantime
this nordstrom 2
pipeline uh that is under construction
russia desperately wants to be completed
uh to go into germany there's a lot of
thought about it as you look at the
graphic of where it goes it's not
finished yet there were
stiff sanctions that are being lifted on
the company that's
constructing it and there's more
reaction to all of that
i understand the state department soon
is going to be releasing a report
regarding the mandatory sanctions um
that congress has
imposed in assisting
on the building of nordstrom 2. so
um i and i understand that the state
department is going to notify congress
soon i'd love to see the argument how
this waiver which benefits
seemingly to me benefits only vladimir
putin
and we've already disadvantaged the
citizens of the united states by
not completing the last hundred yards of
the keystone pipeline
so i don't quite follow how that waiver
the national interest occurs
susan what about this how it plays so
bill bennett said welcome to the job mr
president it is true that the job
is a tough one involves balancing
interest this is another example of that
this is not intended as a decision to
help russia that's a side effect
this is intended as a decision to help
germany
which wanted very much the completion of
the pipeline it puts the administration
in this
uh awkward situation which we've heard
about
uh tony blinken when he was uh in his
confirmation hearings the secretary of
state
said that the united states the biden
administration would you know actively
oppose completion of this pipeline but i
think when the balance of interest came
out
they came out in a different uh position
on that and so
russia reaps the benefits of the desire
of germany
to get this pipeline completed that is
what the administration's saying but it
is
interesting just in the context of the
german elections are coming
uh angela merkel's term as chancellor is
going to be over come september
and the leading party ben is the green
party which actually is opposed to
nordstrom 2
in germany so you're going to have all
kinds of things happening potentially in
coming months
there's a lot of moving parts here and i
think that one of the things that
we really have to appreciate about this
decision is that it really undermines
nato in a lot of different ways it does
not
serve our interest in terms of
benefiting
russia's ability to influence europe and
i think that one of the things that
obviously
president biden ran on as a candidate
was his
criticism of the trump administration as
being too soft on russia
in a lot of different respects you can
debate whether that was true
but from my perspective what we've seen
in the early days from this
administration
is not something that indicates a hard
line toward russia
i will be very curious to see if in
their conversation
vladimir putin and joe biden in the in
the coming weeks if they have any kind
of conversation that includes the name
navalny that is something that i think
may not happen
and if that does not happen it's an
indication that
this is an administration that is not
willing to really stand up and hold the
russians feet to the fire the opposition
leader in russia against
putin very quickly bill the story about
ben sasse
senator sasse having a problem in
grilling this nominee for general
counsel
for the department of national
intelligence because
he did work for huawei the chinese
telecommunications company that
has been under fire and under sanctioned
by
the u.s if through the prism of this
happened in the trump administration
how would it look tonight
yeah well everything would look
different and to the media everything
would be different
ben sasse can be very wrong in my view
can be out on a limb sometimes but today
or yesterday he was right
this very experienced washington
hand this lawyer acting as if you know
he was just helping with administrative
uh uh rules when these administrative
rules
are things they can get around so huawei
can continue its efforts
uh and remember this is a regime that
persecutes the uyghurs
uh and we know about huawei's role in
that uh it's really disgusting what's
going on there
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else